[Music]
hello and welcome i'm grand master
dennis borosch and tonight we're going
to learn about
the pokeman variation so let's take a
look
so in this position bishop f4
and knight ge7 there was a curious
occurrence in the chess world that is
the chess slash streaming world so if
you haven't
noticed there are plenty of new faces
learning the game of chess including
pokemane now she's been getting a lot of
training
with nakamura and rudolf and
many others now as someone who loves
chess
and loves to learn i checked
out anna rudolph teaching pokemane
and they were just learning the smith
mora and here
in this exact position
anna asked pokemane well you are down
upon
which side would you or rather castle
would you castle
short would you castle
long and without a minute of hesitation
pokeman said
of course i would castle long as i would
like to
attack now we all know
that everybody and their grandfather
would castle
short but that it actually made me think
all right it is true the c file
is an issue at the moment
possibly but i was wondering
okay so it does look very risky
to castle long but
is it possible to make it work
so i checked and i checked and i
checked and decided to investigate
ever so deep the variation i realized
this is actually a very interesting idea
by pokeman
so let's take a look at the stem game
that was
played the stem game
is actually played between razuwayev and
berlin in the late 60s
so the idea is not a hundred percent new
but pokey means sort of jogged our
memory
to check it out so
in this game i have long castles
knight g6 bishop g3 so the only issue
with pokeman's idea who's a famous
streamer herself
is to put immediate pressure and start
throwing pawns at her opponent's king
however the issue with the king on c1
that it is kind of running into these
ideas
on the other hand once
we manage to get that king out of the
way we do get this sicilian vibe
more of like the lemirovich attack type
of vibe
so b5 was played bishop b3
b4 knight a4 bishop d7
king b1 not really taking on d6 because
if you do
bishop takes rook takes and then
the idea that was sort of mentioned by
anna and also pokemon agreeing with
her this is not ideal as an id4
check is something you don't want to
face
so something like here knight d4 check
and that is not
awe-inspiring so instead
king b1 was played here
now kimi1 might not be actually the best
move
in fact here white could go for h4 and
h5
immediately which also makes a lot of
sense
now h4h5 would make sense for a couple
of reasons
one of them is to drive away the knight
the second of all
is to get this knight to jump to g5
and attack these all important e6
and f7 squares
now of course white has sacrificed upon
as per gamora but
it is still very very interesting
because if white ever gets f4 f5
in it's going to break through for
certain now in this game king b1 was
played by
razubayev knight a5
you won't believe it the move was
h4 h4
same idea and in fact it's a little bit
better than it was before
the knight has moved to the side but
just like in the velimirovich attack
we really do not care about the
well-being of that knight on
a4 or the bishop on b3 as long as we get
some attacking chances
on the other side of the board namely on
those squares
and if we can attack the d6 pawn
now here black was a little bit scared
of that
played h5 knight g5
very straightforward play and this is
actually what i really liked about
this whole concept and i played myself
this variation because that's the best
way to
investigate i'm going to show a couple
of games
after this one so the very first game
that was played this one and i'm going
to show the games that i played myself
now knight g5 has the same idea and
you're just going for
f4 f5 now if black would try to vacuum
off those pieces of the board
that really wouldn't help anybody as the
black king is still stuck in the middle
and f4 f5 is still on the menu
not to mention even if you'd
dare castle you just castle in to
checkmate
right there and bishop takes g5 h takes
g5
does not look appealing at least not to
me
so here black played bishop b5
and interestingly enough
white decides not to go for queen f3 but
for queen e3
and this is again a typical way of
applying
now if you're not familiar with the
velimirovich valemirovic was a
famous yugoslavian attacking player
they even he was even called the
yugoslav
tal michael who was attacking
a wizard now this is sort of the same
position
white doesn't really care about material
only about attacking chances
so queen e3 what's the point again
of queen e3 the point of queen e3 is you
are going to plant
knight on b6 and maybe even do a knight
b6 knight d5
backflip with the knight and then attack
that way also just sidestepping this
simple idea of attacking the queen
we need three knight takes b3 a b
bishop takes b takes a4 and i can tell
you with
all confidence that this is not the
refutation of the pokeman
in fact baleen did fail to
actually get enough play because think
about it the king on e8
is still stranded over there while
our favorite king is on b1
so the pokemane king is safely tucked
away
over that square so if you want to play
this opening
first rule of thumb get your king
scoot it over to b1 and then start
attacking
queen a5 again not
so productive but white's next move is
super nice
and that is queen f3
what does queen f3 why does queen f3
work so well well
the thing is the weakest link is the f7
pawn
now is double attacked you've got to
defend it
and have to rook c1 there is only one
thing you can do
the only thing that would save you and
that is bishop e7 if you go there
that f7 pawn falls and so does your
position
after queen takes a four rook c8
the first game of the pokeman variation
ended in a resounding victory for
the white player as if you go king d7
i can just take here king takes queen
takes a7 so this kind of
shows that pokeman's idea of long
castling is actually very sound
it might not be um without risks
obviously you are sacrificing upon
you're playing the cis
smith mora you're playing the smith mora
variation
and that does require some risk-taking
but if black is just a little bit
inaccurate you're going to face
some problems so let's take it from the
top
i am going to show you the beginning
part of this variation and then show you
the games i played myself playing the
pokeman variation
you could also go rook simon in that
position
that is correct but
back to the top
e4 c5 d4
so as many of you have mentioned already
this is the smith moor up and the
subvariation being
the pokemon so d4
c takes d4 c3 d takes
knight takes c3 knight c6
bishop c4 so what does white really get
in these type of positions well white
gets a lot of development for the
lack of pawn but black will be
sort of trying to catch up with
development and if
he or she doesn't get that in due time
he's just going to get checkmated
as we've seen earlier e6
knight f3 and there is one
game that i do have to mention because
without that it's never a complete
smith mora recap so if
a6 castle knight e7
bishop g5 b5
yes b5 bishop b3
f6 bishop e3 knight
g6 knight d5 is
actually a very famous game which was
played
by the godfather of the
smith mora and his name is mark esserman
who actually played a beautiful
beautiful game
versus von valley now this is not
the topic of our discussion so i'm not
going to dab too much
in depth with this one but really the
point is after d6
there is a big attack on that stranded
king over on
e8 so if you are
planning to become a big fan of this
myth mora
mark esserman is definitely not to be
forgotten
but back to the
move you can play this variation
and continue on the pokemane thread
and in that case you would go bishop f4
queen e2
and long castles
but okay let's take a look first
at the game i faced so first time i
played it
i faced this move bishop b4
now when your opponent plays bishop b4
it is just too risky to castle long
so the only exception is if you are
facing of bishop b4 you shouldn't
castle long bishop f4 is still the right
move
i'm pressing the d6 square knight f6
and believe it or not you will be
sacrificing
a yet another pawn so e5
knight e4 and i wonder if
the chat can guess the next move
if you can guess the next move you are
born to become a mora player
and a pokemon variation player
and that is it exactly
i guess i was also born amora player
because without a hesitation
i castled what's the point of castling
here
well the point is yes we're losing a
second pawn
but the fact is this bishop is still
mummified over on c8
crying alone well actually not alone
together with
his friends on d8 and a8 and also this
king is sort of
still struck stuck over at e8
knight takes c3 b takes c3
bishop takes c3 and again this is a
critical
moment white is down
two pawns so every move counts
and actually it counts weighted because
if you make one mistake
you're getting very close to lost
however here i wouldn't be
that scared because i feel that the
pressure
over the d6 square is just so strong
that white should be
more than good
now over here you'd think that rook c1
is the best move
but i sort of disagree with that
statement
bishop g5 is an idea but that would
definitely sort of release the tension
and in that case d6 is much
easier to be played and this sad sad
bishop would become a happier one which
we don't want
so instead of rook c1
i play it rook b1 and i'll explain to
you why i played rook b1
instead of rook c1 well rook c1 makes
sense you want to
spend no time waste it
put pressure on the bishop and the
bishop moves then maybe you gain some
time but i had a reverse logic
for that one i felt that hey
you've got a bishop on c3 it's not
actually
that great over there in fact you'd
rather have your bishop on b4
supporting a future d6 break even if it
costs you a pawn
so i decided huh okay in that case i'll
go rogue b1
and i'll say your bishop will be a
constant target
if you ignore it i might just attack it
any old ways i wanted to depending on
the situation and depending on how you
continue on playing
now if you check this with the computer
the computer is still screaming at you
that black is better black is better but
when
you are down a couple of pawns and your
computer is saying
you're 0.4 percent down
which means you are reversed only by
a quarter of a pond not sure if that
means anything at all
that means that your compensation is
real because
according to human math two pawns is two
pawns and not quarter of a pond
therefore white is doing well or at
least has compensation
could black sacrifice on e5
it is an idea but even if you sacrifice
let's say here it takes knight takes e5
it doesn't help you just enough
or i could just take this way if i'm
more
scared of anything and here i can defend
both the bishop and the knight now
even if that happens vine's pieces are
so active and that bishop is so bad
i'm going to say that a million million
times
today but it's just so bad that
uh even having three pawns is not enough
to compensate
so rugby one was played castles now
again i
really want to challenge you guys to
find the next
move for white because
this is the moment you either break
through or
you're going to suffer down a million
pawns
so right now we do have a
firm grip over over over this d6 square
like we have a very nice grip over that
square
which is good news it'll still take a
couple of years till that bishop gets
out to b7
but that only means that we've got
a little bit of extra time to attack
so i see suggestions such as h4
c suggestions such as queen the queen c2
queen d3
and that is actually the ballpark and
that's what you should be looking for
the question is if you play h4 what is
the idea behind that if you play queen
d3 what's the idea behind those moves
so especially in the smith mora you do
have to sort of think a couple of moves
ahead
because otherwise your attack runs out
of steam
i see queen d39 g5 and that is correct
steve north
that's what i played i hid that bishop
with
the straight up idea of attacking the h7
pawn now my plan actually works
brilliantly bishop a5 knight g5
and this rogue b1 actually made sense i
didn't force my opponent to move the
bishop to a better square
i gained time on it and now i'm
attacking the king
immediately
so why not queen c2 and my queen d3
well it has to do with the fact
in case of queen c2 you do not have the
option of rotating and moving your queen
across to h3
and of course we still control that all
important d6 square and that piece
is still sleeping on c8
queen h3 and now h5 is the only move
and when we are on move 14 which is
very early on in a chess game your
opponent has
one i repeat one move left
otherwise he she gets checkmated that is
not a bad sign
so now
in any case i'd sort of
resemble this structure as a some sort
of a pyramid
how can we invade that pyramid
now i feel that we're sort of dominating
this situation
so here we can make it very double-edged
or a no-show for our opponent
i see suggestions such as g4
how else can we storm the castle so to
say
rook lift is an idea but how about
dominating the most important squares
i mean we did succeed creating a swiss
cheese
of our opponent's structure but that's
not always enough
so we have ideas such as the rook b3
rook g3 or g4
and as i see him cooper is saying knight
e4 and that is correct
that's what i played now g4 is not a bad
move
but usually you don't really want to
move pawns in front of your king that
that can become very risky but even all
that
said even that possibly can work and in
case of here
i can take here check takes and
knight e6 is winning but also the very
pretty
takes takes knight f7 is winning
material
because it's a double check and we're
going to also take that queen on
d8 however
whenever you get these dominating
positions you shouldn't
get too risky with your play in fact
knight e4 makes a lot of sense and
that's what i played here i made sure
that i put a lot of pressure in
this position controlling all those
important squares
and now black is in some sort of trouble
because the bishop is on a vacation
somewhere on a5
this bishop we already talked about it
it's basically non-existent
the rest is in the garage so
this does not look good for black
king g7
now we just need to tighten our grip on
the position
and then we'll be celebrating
i mean we can still do the rook lift but
do we really need to
do that you could do this
of course but is that leading to
decisive measures and a decisive
advantage
knight f6 a very nice thought
the only concern i have that you might
allow
some d6 or d5 moves like here d5 moves
and that might not be as
surefire winning the best move as some
of you are pointing out is bishop g5
you are tightening the grip on the
disposition
and you are storming the castle with
bishop f6
king g8 and
well if there is a dream position in the
smith mora
well this is it black basically
cannot move and is just struggling
and now queen e3 yes we are trying to
get the lost treasure over there on h8
and
g7 king h7
knight g5 here now of course here i
could consider
sacrificing but as i said i feel i'm
dominating there is no reason for me
to go all in so i go bishop d3
bishop b6 queen f3
and my unsuspecting opponent said
what about your e5 sponsor
what about that e5 pawn are you going to
sleep well
if i take the e5 pawn what do you guys
think
will i sleep well after knight takes e5
or will i have beautiful dreams about
this game
i might have beautiful dreams about this
game
just a hint
yeah so i played the beautiful queen
takes
h5 sacrifice and here my opponent
realized
that there is no escaping my bishops
those snipers are just putting too much
pressure on that king
here my opponent played knight f3 a
spike check
but i can just capture it now if you
move the rockets just mate in one
and if you take and my opponent was
gracious enough to do so
that is bishop h7 checkmate the king has
nowhere to run to
so this was actually one of the first
games i played
um here but there was another one where
i
actually could play the pokeman
variation
so let me show you that one
as well
um so these games were played online
so those are under some pseudonyms i'm
not 100
sure who these players are
okay so let's pull it up
this was the move
so actually
so we went through bishop f4 the motions
again so a6 bishop f4 and here i castled
knight g6 bishop g3 and instead of b5
which was featured in the razorback game
my opponent played bishop e7
and i played king b1 this is actually
the stem move
you've got to play you want to avoid
any sort of trickery and sorcery on
that file castles
and i do ask you chat if you want to
play the pokemane
you've got to be aggressive
can you tell the next move that i played
here
yep h4 that is really the spirit of this
opening
you are running it down with knight g5
and queen h5
my opponent here sort of got scared and
played
e5 but actually that just plays into my
hands
as that activates my bishop and i get
full
moral compensation maybe even more than
that
now here i actually played an inaccuracy
um i played the very aggressive knight
g5 which does give me play
but it turns out h5 would have been
better
knight f4 takes takes h6
creating a potential mating attack on g7
square
queen d2 hitting on this pawn
potentially setting up some ideas of
attacking that square
and after bishop e6 knight d5 white is
just better as at the end of the day the
f
pawn falls with this king actually very
much
exposed on g8
now instead i went for knight g5 but
then my opponent made this
mistake on f4 knight f4
bishop takes f4 e takes f4 and it is
your time to shine chat
it is one of my recent games yes
yes
yep queen h5
and black is already so here on move 15
and the attack is unstoppable
i have pressure on h7 and f7 and i'm
breaking through
bishop takes g5 wouldn't help at all it
just opens up the file h takes and again
i talked about
this bishop being very strong if g6
that is losing on the spot to this idea
of queen takes g6
and queen g7
so my opponent played h6 bishop takes f7
rook takes queen takes here and queen g6
and soon after
i won the game but if my opponent would
go
k8 i have queen g6
takes h takes and if knight e5
rook takes gh and queen takes h6 is
mating on the spot
so that sort of shows that
a bit of an accuracy in the
opening is enough to lose the thread
and lose the game
so i do want to show
one more thing about this variation
so let's go back to our tibia position
queen e2 a6 bishop f4
knight e7 long castles knight g6
bishop g3 bishop e7
and here again as we talked about it
king b1 is the critical move
now if black would be a little bit
unsuspecting go
b5 bishop b3 and queen c7
in fact white can also switch around
realizing that the king is still in the
middle
white could go rook c1 put pressure on
that queen
and if castles could do the typical
sacrifice of
knight d5 he takes bishop takes d5
bishop d7 takes takes knight d4
takes queen takes e4 and even though
here black does keep that extra pawn
after knight f5 white gets ample
compensation
for the sacrificed pawn so
instead of b5 going back
here castles
there is this move of h4
actually bishop b3 first queen c7
h4 and here one of the ideas
for black is to go towards this idea of
b5 and knight a5
but one really doesn't care and you
don't have to
worry about that white is just going to
do the same
thing over again b5
here comes the next big move for white
so actually i want to ask you chad to
guess
the next move because
if you find it you actually have the
rhythm of the pokeman variation
so just remember you must go forward
and attack just use
the knowledge you've got that you've
heard and listened to in a few
minutes ago just a few minutes ago you
heard
the right maneuver
so in fact it's not h5
now my plan so in that previous example
h5 was stronger but my original idea of
knight g5 wasn't wrong
and in fact my g5 should be played here
now white could actually
face something like knight a5 bishop
c2 knight e5 f4
knight c4 e5 but in this case
white really gets some good play and if
h6 there is
queen e4
attacking and if g6
knight takes f7 is a beautiful sacrifice
king f7 is checkmate and if you go rook
takes f7
the punch line is after queen takes a8
the rook is not on f8 so there's no
point and there's no way of trapping the
queen the queen will be able to come
back
so that is one of the ideas but the big
question is
isn't it that there's age six
but i wonder are we going backwards
in the pokeman variation hint hint
[Music]
no
what is the difference the difference is
that the opponent didn't make e5
weakening moves
compared to my game played
well sacrificing on these squares we're
not quite ready for that
but just channel your inner fischer play
channel your inner velomirovic attacking
jeans can attack those pawns later on
how can you try to undermine the e6 and
f7 pawn chain
f4 indeed f4 and the whole point
is you do not care for the safety of
this knight in fact
you want it to be taken if you take it
well go ahead take that one you don't
care
um in fact this is why i feel
that this can become a very promising
weapon
i definitely advise all of you to pick
up this weapon of
the pokeman variation because it can
very much lead to lively games so let's
take a look what happens if
h takes well in that case we capture
back
with h takes g5 and yes we are down a
piece
but our queen is immensely
coming close to h5 rook d8
queen h5 and if knight a5
believe it or not in a couple of
movements already over
try to move and finish the game and
style
so it seems that the king on g8 is safe
but is really unlike that
it turns out that it is actually doomed
because the bishop on e7 acts like a
dummy piece
sort of taking away the e7 square
and that means it's just game over
after queen h7 check king f8
queen h a check takes
and rook takes h8 checkmate
quite an exquisite checkmate if you ask
me
so this is the pokemane variation this
is the
long castle variation in the smith mora
so it's a smith mora
pokemane sub variation and i really hope
i managed to ignite
your interest and i hope you will have
fun
trying it and playing it yourself thank
you so much for watching
have a good night
you